JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Hello everyone.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
Welcome to YouTube
Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
In the studio, let me introduce
our guests.
Hannah Eaves from Link TV.
How are you doing, Hannah?
HANNAH EAVES: I'm very
well, thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How
was your vacation?
HANNAH EAVES: It was awesome.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Did you
go somewhere exciting?
HANNAH EAVES: I did.
I went to Greece and Turkey and
I'm feeling very mellow
and relaxed.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great frame
of mind for this show.
We have Darin Wilson.
How are you Darin?
DARIN WILSON: Good, thank
you very much.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I hear you
were driving down from the
wine country today
for the show.
DARIN WILSON: Petaluma, yes
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
well I really appreciate that.
I know it's hard to get out of
the wine country to Silicon
Valley, but we are hopefully
going to make it worth your
trip today.
DARIN WILSON: For you guys,
I'm happy to do it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank
you for saying that.
Jeremy Wilson, my
famous co-host.
JEREMY WALKER: Hello.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How are
you doing, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: I'm doing
pretty well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I heard you
got a lot of sleep last night.
JEREMY WALKER: I
got a lot, yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Which is
about six hours, right?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, six
hours broken up.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's good.
I think you look a lot
better than usual.
JEREMY WALKER: The caffeine
is keeping me alive.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And
then live from New
York, Jeremy Posnick.
How are you doing, Jeremy?
Sorry, Jeff.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah,
I'm doing well.
I'll take Jeremy's identity.
Hi everybody.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I am slightly
jet-lagged I must admit.
I just got back from South Korea
about 24 hours ago, so
you're going to have
to forgive me when
I mix up your names.
OK, so let's get into it.
We will talk about Link TV.
For those of you that are not
familiar with it, we'll give
you a great introduction.
We're planning a little demo.
And then we'll drill into the
technical aspects of their
integration with YouTube
and YouTube APIs.
And then towards the end of
the show, Jeff is going to
tell us a little bit more of
what's happening in the stack
overflow space.
Because we've been getting a lot
of high quality questions.
So we thought it might be a
good idea to cover some of
them live on the show.
And then, as always, if you have
any questions about what
we are covering today, please
ask them using the moderator
link that is in the
YouTube embed.
So let's start with
you, Hannah.
So tell me about Link TV.
HANNAH EAVES: Well, Link TV is
an independent nonprofit
national television channel on
Dish and DirecTV in about 33
million US households.
It was founded in 1999 by
a group of independent
television producers who wanted
an opportunity to try
and bring international
programming to American audiences.
So particularly news,
documentaries, world cinema,
international music--
basically different
perspectives to American audiences.
For instance, we were one of the
first broadcasters of Al
Jazeera English.
We were actually the first
national broadcaster of Al
Jazeera English in America,
which I think was very
important at a time
per September 11.
And we got a lot of attention
for our bringing international
perspectives to American
audience.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I can totally
relate to that as
somebody with immigrant
background.
So is it an IPTV station?
Is it traditional broadcast?
Tell me a little bit more
about the distribution.
HANNAH EAVES: It is on Dish
and DirecTV in the basic
packages, so satellite, and also
in some local cable areas
in smaller chunks
of programming.
But also we recently announced
we'll be merging with KCT in
Los Angeles.
And they have I think a little
over 5 million cable
households in the Los
Angeles area.
And pretty soon you'll be seeing
more of our programming
in LA I think.
On top of that, over the last
five years, we've been moving
a lot into the digital world.
So part of what I'm going to be
demoing today is a move we
made into the iPad.
And also, we have a
corresponding website and
Google TV app.
So we're definitely moving
as much as we can
into digital delivery.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then can
you give us a little sense of
your size as it relates to
independent broadcasters.
Are you kind of in the middle,
or are you a large one or a
small one for those
who are not very
familiar with the scope--
HANNAH EAVES: We're large--
especially when you
add KCT into the
mix, we're very large--
for being an independent
television channel.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great, so for
some of our audience who
have been following our blog,
they have read about
viewchange.org, which is
something that we talked about
probably a little
over a year ago.
What's the relationship between
viewchange.org and Link TV?
HANNAH EAVES: Well,
viewchange.org was a project
of Link TV.
We received funding from the
Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation to build a video
website that focused and
brought together hundreds
of videos about global
development and progress being
made in the developing world.
And so it was for that project
that we developed a kind of
new stream of technologies.
And part of that was integrating
the YouTube API.
And also doing natural language
processing on the
metadata around video in order
to do intelligent search to
bring up related content from
around the web that was
relevant to the video
you were watching.
And also, that meant that we
could create an archive of 450
high quality videos and also
connect them to the latest
news, the latest videos, so
down the road, the content
remained relevant.
So that was kind of our first
step into this new video
technology.
And then we received funding
from the Bertha Foundation,
which is a great London-based
foundation, to take that same
technology and apply it
to global news videos.
And in between there, we got
funding from the Knight
Foundation to basically build a
prototype of this new global
news video system online.
And we did research with 16-
to 24-year-olds about their
news habits.
So this has kind of been an
ongoing process for us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great, and
then for those of you that
have been following, you might
have noticed that actually
viewchange.org has open
source implementation.
So if somebody wants to take a
stab at deploying their own,
they could actually get
the source code and
play around with it.
HANNAH EAVES: Yeah,
it's on GitHub.
It's called the Link
TV platform.
That is prior to a lot of the
changes we've made to support
this new global news site.
But yes, the core architecture
is there on GitHub.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You also won
the Peabody Award, right?
Can you tell me more about it?
HANNAH EAVES: Yeah,
so that was--
after September 11th, Link
thought about what was missing
from American broadcasting.
And part of that was
perspectives
from the Middle East.
So we started this show called
Mosaic: World News From The
Middle East, where we monitored
about 40 different
Middle Eastern broadcasters
every night.
And then we take 10 to 15
segments of those, translate
them into English, do English
language voice-overs, and then
package them together
into a nightly
half hour news program.
And so we won a Peabody for that
show because it was such
a unique way of bringing--
what is the Iranian state
television saying about
something that's happening in
Iran instead of just, what is
America thinking about that?
As well as what's Al Jazeera
Arabic saying on the ground in
the Middle East?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And this
is very important in my
experience-- obviously
the perspective.
It makes a huge difference.
So how does Link TV
get their content?
You mentioned that for the
Middle East coverage, you
obtain content, you
repackage it.
Can you tell us more about where
the content comes from?
HANNAH EAVES: Yeah, we go to
international festivals, we
have relationships with
international distributors.
And so we hand select specific
documentaries that don't get a
lot of airplay in the US.
Also occasionally we stumble
across some great
international show.
We have a Danish show called
Borgen right now, which has
been a huge success for us.
We've got a double-page
spread in Newsweek.
Everyone loves it.
It won the BAFTA in the UK for
its airing on BBC, but no one
in America is showing it.
So we have relationships with
certain distributors and we
pick up programming that way.
So you'll see in the app, we
have a whole documentary
section that's all
acquired content.
And then we create shows
like Mosaic.
We also have another program
called LinkAsia, which is a
weekly news program where we
have correspondents on the
ground in certain
Asian cities.
And then we have them report on
stories that might not make
it to America.
They look at what's breaking in
social networks in China,
translate that out of Chinese,
and look at stories from those
perspectives.
So it's mostly acquired content
from distributors and
also international news
broadcasters, and also a
little bit of original
production.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I was told
that you also curate content
from YouTube.
HANNAH EAVES: Yes, we do.
We curate I'd say--
you'll see when we demo the
app-- probably about 80% of
the content in the app is
curated from YouTube.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So maybe we
should switch and look at the
app a little bit and then
drill into some of the
technical aspects.
Because I know Jeremy is jumping
up and down ready to
ask some questions of Darin.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, I'm
ready to get started
with some of those.
HANNAH EAVES: OK, well I'll jump
onto the iPad over here.
Let's take a look at this.
Need to get back on here--
all right-- it might take
it minute to load up.
This is the Link TV World
News iPad app.
You can download this now.
It's now available through
the App Store.
If you just search for Link
TV it'll come up.
So what you see here is a pretty
standard presentation.
We wanted to take how we curate
global news for the
television channel and
apply it to this app.
So you can see, we have a
variety of sources here from
AP, Euronews, Al Jazeera
English, ITN.
We try and curate as
much as we can--
Press TV, Current TV--
off of YouTube.
And then we're also, like I
said, doing some of this
translation from Arabic and
also Asian language new
sources that we put up.
And this is a mix of
international stories that you
might not have seen covered
so much in the US media,
and also raw video.
So we do a lot of trying to find
what is the best, most
important, eyewitness videos
you can see out of, for
instance, the Gaza conflict
or something like that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is raw video a
technical concept or is that
a journalistic concept?
HANNAH EAVES: It's just a
journalistic concept.
It just means--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: When I hear
raw video, I think in terms of
the bytes and the bits.
HANNAH EAVES: Oh right.
No, it's just that
it's unedited.
So it's not edited.
It's not wrapped up
in a broadcast,
which I think is really--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So it's like,
user generated content
might fall into that
kind of category?
HANNAH EAVES: Citizen
journalism?
Yes, definitely.
So we were trying to find
the best pieces
of eyewitness accounts.
So if I pick a video here--
here's Obama's
recent trip to Myanmar.
And so you can see here we go
into a video that this is
where the natural language
processing is happening.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How so?
Can you explain how
that works?
HANNAH EAVES: This is a
Telegraph TV piece--
Sure, so we partner
with Zemanta.
I don't know if you're
familiar with them.
They do the natural language
processing on the title and
the metadata that we're pulling
from YouTube, in this
case from Telegraph TV's
YouTube channel.
And then they feed back to
us what people, places,
organizations, topics, are
covered within the video.
So this is something I know
that you guys have started
integrating.
But this was--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Similar
to what Freebase
topics API does, right?
HANNAH EAVES: Exactly, except
we built this two years ago.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure, that's
why you're here.
HANNAH EAVES: And so, as you
guys are doing, we tied these
to Freebase IDs so you can see
underneath the video here--
if you're not familiar with the
people or places covered
in the video, you can tab
through these tabs down here
and get background information
about everything that's
covered in the video.
And that's all automated.
And this information is being
pulled from Freebase.
And if there's no Freebase
record, then we use DBpedia.
So we kind of have a fallback.
You can follow any of these
topics, and I'll show you that
feature in just a second.
That means that any time
something new comes up that's
relevant to what you're
following, it'll come up in
the My Links section.
And then we also use that same
system to call up related
videos from elsewhere
on the web and
related articles as well.
Not sure why we're not--
let's take a look at
another video here.
We should be seeing some
related articles
as well down here.
So here you see, we have
related articles.
And we have thousands of sources
that we're scraping to
bring up related articles.
We're using Daylife for that,
, as well as Zemanta.
And so if there is an article--
like here's a Globe
and Mail article that I'm
interested in reading that's
about the same thing that's
covered in the video.
It brings up the whole Globe and
Mail website so you don't
have to leave the app.
You can dig deeper, you can
learn more about a topic.
You can then go in and read
some articles about what's
covered in the video without
ever having to leave the app.
We also have this feature
called In Depth.
Sorry, I keep on accidentally
updating here.
Here we go, so here's
an In Depth feature.
This is where we pull
together a playlist.
We might have curated 30 videos
about the Gaza conflict.
Here's a place where you can
look at that playlist and
watch all of those videos
back to back.
And then also on this page we
curate and key tweets and
articles and ways you
can take action.
Although, I'm having trouble
loading this page right now.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So while
we're loading, I had a
question about--
how do you actually decide
what to show to
a particular user?
So when I fire up the app, I get
a view of the content that
you have curated.
Is there any personalization
capability?
Can I pick topics that I care
about or news stations that I
care about?
HANNAH EAVES: Yep, you
can pick topics
that you care about.
Here we go.
You can follow news stories.
And I'm going to jump right
into that here.
Here you could see
the story page.
I think what's interesting
about this In
Depth feature is also--
and all the pages we
try to do this--
there's an action that
you can take.
So in some pieces, it
might be donating--
if it's something about women's
rights, it might be
send a child to school,
send a care package,
something like that.
Here it's learn more about the
Israeli-Hamas conflict.
So you can see, here's the
playlist of 38 videos.
You can watch those
back to back.
You can see key tweets.
I think this was really good
for us on election night.
It's really like a live blogging
kind of platform.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How do you
know what actions to associate
with which topics?
HANNAH EAVES: That's the one
piece that's not automated in
our whole system.
So it really is a matter of
researching what topic-- and
we've had a long history of
trying to associate action
with content.
So it's calling on that
institutional
knowledge to go back.
And we also have a lot of
partners that we've done
programs with, like Save
the Children and Oxfam
and places like that.
So here is the much talked
about My Link
personalization page.
If you reach this page and
you're not following anything
yet-- like I said before,
I showed you you
could follow topics.
We suggest things that you might
be wanting to follow.
So here we have a few different
pieces-- you might
want to follow the Syrian
civil war or
anti-austerity protests.
You might want to
follow sources--
Al Jazeera English, LinkAsia.
And so now if I--
let's see, I'm going
to follow--
oh David Patraeus, oh dear.
You might not want to follow
self-immolation.
That's a bit of a hardcore
topic there.
So now, if I refresh this page,
you can see how we then
display all of the latest
content for all the things
you're following as well as
pulling out specific videos.
If there have been any in the
last five days, we pull those
out to the forefront.
And so now there's all this
content that is being curated
based on your interest.
And we also have a Documentaries
section.
For instance, "Crisis" is
a great documentary.
We have a selection
of documentaries.
You can see here we have
some Vice guides.
So we partnered with Vice
and acquired some
content from them.
I know there's also a lot of
Vice content up on YouTube.
And other feature length
documentaries--
you can see here this is a good
example of the way you
can take an action.
You can donate to help better
the lives of India's poor on
this page specifically.
And there's one last thing
I'm going to show you.
We build a map feature
as well.
I think that it's really
important for us as a globally
focused news app for you to be
able to really look deeply
into specific regions.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Really cool.
So what are the squares?
What do they represent?
HANNAH EAVES: Pardon?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: The squares
of the map, what do they--
HANNAH EAVES: They represent
where there are videos.
And here we go.
You can go last 24, last
week, or last month.
We'll zoom in a little bit here
and you'll be able to
see, for instance, how we can
break out areas specifically
in places like Syria
where you could see
Aleppo versus Damascus.
It's taking a little while
because of-- last month we had
hundreds of videos.
Now we have an editorial
staff running 24/7.
We have staff based in
different cities.
And so we're adding content--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the videos
are geocoded when you
upload them for your content,
and then for YouTube you're
using the geolocation-based
search?
HANNAH EAVES: No
right now we're
doing everything manually.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So they are
curated since I think there
are still a lot of videos on
YouTube that don't actually
have the tags.
I see.
HANNAH EAVES: Again, it's taking
a second to load here.
Here we go.
Look at all those squares.
So if I zoom in here say,
for instance to Syria--
you can see a little drawer
comes out if I tap on Syria.
We have 10 videos here, but
then we also have--
I'll do this from the side.
It's a little tricky,
much more granular.
So we have Aleppo, areas I
can't pronounce sadly--
I need my Arabic team here to
pronounce everything for us.
But I think you get a good
idea of the depth of
international content we're
curating in here from
all over the world.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This
is really cool.
I see you have something
in Poland as well.
HANNAH EAVES: Do we?
Ah no, sadly.
I should have had them
add something just
before we did this.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
well this is great.
Thank you so much for running
the demo for us.
It's a very interesting app.
And I understand the app has
been quite successful in the
store since you have
released it.
HANNAH EAVES: Yeah when they
launched, we were number one
in the news category and
number 25 overall.
And I think we've been able to
maintain a fairly good rate of
organic downloads.
And we've gotten a lot
of really great
comments and ratings.
We're, like, this close
to having five stars.
It's like four stars and
7/8 of a fifth star.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Ok great,
maybe the audience on the show
and I will check out this app
and contribute to some of the
good ratings.
Especially given that this is
all very nice and easy to use,
but when you look under the
hood, there's actually some
heavy lifting going on with
[INAUDIBLE] analysis and
geoinformation.
So it's very nicely done.
So let's switch to the
technical part.
I understand Darin is here and
he's a developer at Link TV.
So Darin, tell us more about
the implementation.
DARIN WILSON: I just want to say
hello to my partner Chuck,
who's in the peanut
gallery there.
The two of us did all of the
development, at least on the
front end of the app.
The nice thing about when we
started, the news site was
already up and running.
So we had a backend in place
that we could build off of.
The CMS that the editors used
to input videos and edit
things was already in place.
They didn't have to learn
anything new.
Some new features like the In
Depth feature that Hannah just
showed was brand new, so
we had to build out
some backend then.
But we had a good solid
base to start with.
JEREMY WALKER: I am always
curious, what languages did
you use and why did
you go that route?
DARIN WILSON: The backend
was written in Rails.
And I inherited that.
I just started at Link
about a year ago.
But I was coming from a Rails
shop so that felt pretty
comfortable.
For the front end, we sort of
went back and forth on whether
we were going to do native or do
something using HTML5 like
PhoneGap or one of those
technologies.
And we did a lot of research and
talked to a lot of people.
And the overall feeling we got
was, to get the best and
smoothest experience performance
wise, you were
going to be better
off going native.
The HTML5, at least a year ago,
wasn't quite there yet in
terms of smoothness and speed.
And so we decided just
to dive right in and
implement it native.
So we used the standard iOS
framework and Objective-C for
the client.
And then communicated--
we added a REST-like API for the
backend that was just for
the iPad app.
Hanna didn't mention this, but
we also released a Google TV
app at about the same time that
the iPad app launched.
So we used the REST API
for that as well.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Can you tell us a little
bit about how you
use the YouTube APIs?
DARIN WILSON: A few
different ways.
First off, the website,
news.linktv.org, uses
[INAUDIBLE]
Player for displaying the
YouTube content there.
We also used the data
API in the backend.
So when an admin finds a video
on YouTube that they like and
they want to add to the site,
they just drop a URL in and
then the data API runs and
fetches all the metadata.
So they don't have to copy over
the description or the
duration or the title
or any of that.
That works very nicely.
And then in the front end, the
actual video window that you
see is the iOS webview.
And we're using the embed
player API, the iFrame.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Was there anything that
surprised you as you were
integrating, maybe with
the player API or
even the data API?
DARIN WILSON: Yeah, I think
the first surprise was--
we thought, OK, how do
you drop a YouTube
video into an iOS app?
Well, there's got to be an
Objective-C control for that.
And then we looked around
and said, nope.
Because we know there was a
YouTube app, so we thought,
we'll just use whatever
they're using.
But it turns out, no, you just
drop a little webview in there
and use the same technology
used for the website.
So that was kind
of a surprise.
But there was some nice sample
code to start with.
And I was talking to Chuck
right before we started.
And he dropped it in, and in
about half a day it was
working pretty quickly.
It's always nice when you see
some sample code and you drop
it in and it works
the first time.
Very often, you get a surprise,
sometimes a bad one.
There's some little strange
bug or the sample code was
posted two years ago and
it's not the same.
But the documentation was nice
and up-to-date, so it worked
the first time.
Then we just kind of refined
it from there.
JEREMY WALKER: OK great.
So I'm guessing--
from feedback, you're saying it
sounds like you're hoping
for an iOS native app.
Is there anything else that
comes to mind on anything
you're integrating?
Maybe just for general feedback,
we always like to
hear a little bit about that.
DARIN WILSON: Well, I mean
obviously if there were a
native iOS control that did
YouTube, that would be that
sort of pie in the sky dream.
But even then, I think it would
be nice just to see more
code samples of iOS
integration.
Particularly, the piece we
stumbled on a little bit,
which took a little research
to figure out, was
communication between
the video player
and the native app.
Because we wanted to do some
things, first of all with
analytics--
to know how long someone played
a video, like when they
paused it, when they left.
And we also wanted to make the
launch a little bit smoother.
So we've got these nice Reuters
images that we use for
the videos and we wanted that
image to be up there while the
video was loading.
And getting the message back
from the player that it was,
not only ready and not only
cued, but actually playing,
took a little bit of research
and a little bit of
experimentation to find out.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So Darin, to
that point, it sounds like you
were using the iFrame embed in
the UIWebView and then the
JavaScript iFrame API to
actually kick off the video
playback since | noticed you
have your own control of-- the
player button is uniform across
all the different types
of content.
And then in addition, you said
you have been able to track
the communications between
the iFrame [INAUDIBLE]
machine in your app.
So how is that piece done?
DARIN WILSON: That was
another surprise.
We researched a lot to see,
how are people doing this?
And it turned out the prevailing
method was for
JavaScript to fire off a
location change, so setting
window.location to
something else.
Because that is actually
an event that
the iOS webview tracks.
It's one of the few
that will do that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This is like
the smoke signal equivalent of
the modern age, because
it's kind of low-tech.
DARIN WILSON: Exactly,
so you fire off a
location change and then--
so we just created these--
they're not really URLs, they're
just kind of messages.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I
call that-- it's
a First World problem.
DARIN WILSON: Right, exactly.
So we catch that and then based
on the event, we look at
it and say, OK, it looks like
it's been paused or it looks
like it's been playing.
So let's do something
in response to that.
And then to go the other
direction, the iOS webview has
a call that will let
you just execute
JavaScript at that level.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So this
is how you can call the
JavaScript API method from
the Objective-C code.
DARIN WILSON: Yeah which,
at this point
we're not doing anymore.
But one rev, we were
doing that.
So that's how we handled the
bidirectional communication.
So it was a little chunky, and
sort of surprising once we saw
the method.
But once we tried it, it
worked terrifically.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, it
seems to work pretty
nice in your app.
DARIN WILSON: Yeah, thank you.
JEREMY WALKER: Great, so have
you guys had a chance to try
to new data API or the
new analytics API?
DARIN WILSON: No, we haven't
put that in.
We've been so focused on the
iPad app that we haven't
looked at the backend stuff.
Particularly there's a
case of, if it ain't
broke, don't fix it.
The network is working fine.
But I saw your show a few weeks
ago, when Shawn Simister
was here showing off the
Freebase connection.
And that would be great because
as Hannah mentioned,
we rolled all that
stuff ourselves.
So if there were a way to
leverage what we're already
doing with communicating with
the data API to get more of
the top information back, we
could cut out a bunch of code
and not have to maintain
it anymore.
HANNAH EAVES: And Darin is
a Freebase alum as well.
DARIN WILSON: I worked at
Metaweb years ago at the very
beginning, when Freebase was
just a twinkle in Danny
Hillis's eye.
Yeah, I worked on the
first version of it.
And so a lot of those guys
I know after the Google
acquisition happened.
So it's kind of fun because it
was this thing I worked on
years ago and thought how
this might get used.
And we wondered about it.
And then, when Google picked it
up, it got more widespread.
And now I'm using it as a client
in my own package.
Not something I ever would've
imagined but--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you
probably won't be complaining
too much if it doesn't work as
well a you think it should.
DARIN WILSON: Well if it
doesn't, I know who to call.
One of my friends will
get an email.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well
we're very excited
about the topics API.
I think so far the feedback
has been very encouraging.
We'll be looking forward for
developers to adopt it.
And Jeff has put up very
nice code samples
around it as well.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah,
it's really nice.
When you do a search, you can
add a topics ID and it helps
make that search much better.
DARIN WILSON: That was actually
the thing we talked
about at the very beginning.
If someone types B-A-S-S into
a search engine, how do we
know if it's a musical
instrument, a fish, or a beer?
Because back then you couldn't
really do that.
My voice is squeaking.
I'm Peter Brady all
of a sudden.
Excuse me.
Must be the early hour.
So now we're really seeing
that happen in
action and it's terrific.
HANNAH EAVES: I forgot to
mention, another piece of us
taking the YouTube content
is that we--
and I think a lot of people as
they start thinking about how
to build apps around
YouTube content--
we spent a lot of time thinking,
how do we package
YouTube content so that it's
more attractive to the user on
the frontend experience?
Which is why we have a
subscription to Reuters Images.
And we also have some fantastic
headline writers.
So we try and give more context
to the YouTube videos
through using the metadata.
But then we also try and wrap
it in a pretty package.
Choosing really striking imagery
and catchy headlines,
and also headlines that might
tell you a little bit more
about what's going on
in the larger frame.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Rather
than "video001.--"
HANNAH EAVES: Exactly.
We don't see too
many of those.
But we definitely do with
the raw video for sure.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think
I'm slowly getting
the raw video concept.
HANNAH EAVES: Well you know, in
all the research we did--
we did Bertha National
Survey and we did a
lot of market research.
And also, like I said, this
white paper we did with 16- to
24-year-olds about their
news habits.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
I saw that.
It's available on
your site right?
HANNAH EAVES: Yeah,
news.linktv.org--
that's the website version
of the app--
/whitepaper.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Anybody
who is interested in
user-generated content-- or
as you call it, citizen
journalism--
I think it's a very
interesting read.
HANNAH EAVES: Yeah, I mean raw
video, just the interest in
raw video amongst young
people, is enormous.
You guys know this.
At YouTube, when something
breaks, everyone's really
looking for the eyewitness
accounts.
And then people also then want
to step back and really
understand the larger context.
But I think, in the moment, raw
video is of such interest
and there's a lot of distrust
towards produced news content
from broadcasters.
A lot of pretty sophisticated
media understanding I think
from young people which
was surprising to us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, that
was I think one of the
surprising finds that I saw
in the paper as well.
Jeremy, do you have any other
tricky questions for Darin?
JEREMY WALKER: I think we can
just close with-- and by the
way, thanks for sharing
all this.
Do you have any feedback you'd
like to give to developers who
are just starting their own
integrations with the YouTube
APIs, or [INAUDIBLE]
for the data APIs?
DARIN WILSON: No, nothing too
much beyond definitely start
with a sample code because
that's going to get
to 90% of the way.
And then, make sure to review.
I just learned a couple things
about the API this morning
from Jarek when we were
talking before.
So, go over the documentation
with a fine-toothed comb
because there are some things
in there that will surprise
you and help you.
JEREMY WALKER: Great, so kick
it over to Jeff I guess.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, thanks
a lot for sharing all your
experience.
We have a few minutes left, so
I know Jeff wanted to tell us
a little bit more about what's
happening in the stack
overflow space.
Jeff, any interesting questions
that came up recently?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sure, well,
I'm a little biased.
I think all the questions
are interesting.
There is one in particular that
I wanted to highlight
that we got from a developer
recently.
This actually points a little
bit to a deficiency in our
sample code.
Thanks for that very
interesting talk.
I certainly appreciate the fact
that we do need to have
good examples out there, because
that's what developers
are building on.
So the one question I wanted
to highlight--
I'm going to actually start
screen sharing right now, so
you will not be able to see me
anymore, but I'm going to pull
up the question.
This is about how you can "like"
a specific video in
using version three of the API,
which is a new version we
released a few weeks ago.
And, if you read through
the question--
and by the way there's a link
to the specific question
posted on our Plus YouTube Dev
Google+ page right now if you
wanted to go back later.
But basically if you look
through what the developer's
initially doing, they
were trying to
insert an activity basically.
And that's a very natural thing
to expect yourself to be
able to do.
Because you can actually read
the activity feed and you can
get information about the videos
that have been "like"d
from there.
So it logically makes sense.
Well, why can't I just post
something to that activity
feed and add [INAUDIBLE]
via that mechanism.
Unfortunately though,
that's not actually
how things are done.
So I wanted to explain
what I put into the
answer to that question.
And basically, this ties into
how we treat pretty much
everything in version three
of the API as a playlist.
So things that version two
had their own standalone
endpoints--
the Favorites feed, for
instance, or the--
I guess there wasn't
even a Liked Videos
feed in version two.
But there's a severed endpoint
for "like"ing video.
Watch Later was also treated
as something special.
Those are more or less coalesced
into the general
idea of a playlist in version
three of the API.
And that does simplify
some things.
It means that you don't
have to write special
purpose code for--
"like"ing a video or adding a
video as a favorite is all
pretty much the same operation,
but you pass in a
different playlistId.
So the basic way you'll want to
do this is by first making
an authenticated call to
channels.list, which is
something that gives
information about your channel.
You could pass in the parameter
mine=true and you'll
get information back about
your specific channel.
And you'll get back this list
over here if you specify
part=contentDetails.
And this contains the specific
IDs that correspond to your
own Likes playlist and
Favorites playlist.
Also the Uploads, Watch Later,
and Watch History playlists.
And all of those playlists can
be read from if you do
standard playlist
items dot list.
And some of them can do to write
operations and add new
videos to it.
So the way you do the "like"
operation, getting back to the
initial question, is that you
take the ID that you get back
from your channels.list call--
an implementation detail, right
now at least they're all
prefixed with LL for the Likes
playlist and FL for the
Favorites playlist.
Please don't hard code that.
It's much better to do what
we're recommending here, which
is try to retrieve this
playlistID dynamically.
Just in case we ever change
anything in the future,
hard-coded logic is a great
way to run into
problems down the line.
So get this Likes playlistID
and then you could do a
standard playlist
items insert.
Here's a sample of the body
that you would do.
In this case, you pass
in the playlistId and
you pass in the videoId.
It's again very similar to how
you do the Favorites insert if
you want to "favorite" a video,
if you want to add a
video, any arbitrary playlist.
Hopefully that simplifies
things for a
developer moving forward.
Part of the problem, in going
back to what I was saying
about simple code, is that
there's no code sample for
this right now in the docs.
So as part of answering this
question, I also submitted a
code sample that should
hopefully show up pretty soon
within our online code
samples in the docs.
So if you're somewhere down the
line looking for similar
code, you should be able to
find it pretty easily.
That's the main thing I
wanted to point out.
There are a bunch of other
interesting questions on stack
overflow but we'll save some
more for next week.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool, thanks
for covering that Jeff.
I think the moral of the story
is that the world is nothing
but a playlist.
JEFFREY POSNICK: There you go.
Playlists everywhere.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
so I think we have just a
little bit of time left to
look at the questions.
I see one question
that is relevant.
I think this one's addressed
to you, Jeremy.
Is YouTube Google developer
relations hiring?
JEREMY WALKER: Yes we are.
We're always hiring.
Go check it out at
developers.google.com/jobs and
feel free to apply.
We're always looking for help.
And I think that's the only
question actually.
Yeah, so if you're interested,
definitely go check out that
page, read a little
bit about it.
We'd love to hear from you,
so definitely apply.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great, well
thank you very much for
joining us on the show today
Darin and Hannah.
Jeff, thanks for joining
from New York City.
And it was a pleasure
to have you on the
show co-hosting, Jeremy.
And I guess we'll see
you next week?
JEREMY WALKER: I'll
be in Brazil.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's true,
we won't see you, but--
Jeff I think you're on mute.
OK, you're no longer on mute.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I think I'll
be flying solo next week.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, great,
until next week then.
JEREMY WALKER: All right
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Bye.
DARIN WILSON: Thank you.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Bye everybody.